13 here on a monday morning detecting
lung cancer early hospitals are using ct
technology to screen patients here in
the valley and that's so important
because catching it early often leads to
a higher chance of successful treatment
and as you know smoking is the nation's
leading cause of preventable death and
unfortunately the rates here in nevada
are very high hector mejia live near
sunrise hospital with some details about
this screening program hector
now well the difference now is that this
technology is more widely available and
more affordable than what it was before
they're using greater technology to
screen people for lung cancer and here's
what doctors are looking for something
called lung nodules the program at the
sunrise hospital system involves the use
of ct scans that are usually performed
for other reasons say a car crash or a
cough
scientific studies have shown dramatic
improvement in lung cancer survival with
the application of ct scanners
it's very interesting to note that
only 15 percent of the time
are we actually looking for a lung
cancer 85 percent of the time we find it
looking for other things like broken
bones pneumonias coughs covered 19.
if lung cancer is treated in the in its
early stages there's a higher chance of
successful treatment
patients over the age of 55 with an
extensive smoking history are at high
risk and here's another reason why this
is so important tobacco use takes an
estimated 4 000 lives each year here in
nevada alone and that is according to
the american lung association reporting
live hector mejia live local now